how's this beginning of day any day how
is this how's this yes so the
interesting thing about doing this for a
show like this is I assume that you guys
had to figure out a way to describe this
show in as quick away as possible have
you fit have you figured out an elevator
pitch okay no still a golf intendant's
it gets exciting - yeah
is there anything you focus on is there
anything useful we focus on with The
Witcher when you when you want to talk
about birds you know not sell The
Witcher but explain why they should be
hyped for the witcher's anything you
focus on with this show yeah family yeah
absolutely family with every you know
all the rien santa c elements that
fantasy show has it's full of adventure
and magic and infighting and very
vibrant and yes it's got it's got
everything but like Freya said it's its
family's house everything together as
well it's like really big relatable
themes and it's great because you get
those kind of big action scenes which
are exciting and but at the same time
you get moments where it's still and you
can really kind of see see the
characters and I think that's also
really important to have that balance so
it's kind of got all the mm-hmm
it's interesting because and and this is
this might touch a little bit on spoiler
territory so I I won't post this into
the show comes out but it's interesting
that the core of the show is your two
characters and girl and a lot of people
want to see the see them come together
but a lot of this season you're
separated so I'm wondering how you
approached the be the loneliness or the
the the searching for each other aspect
of the character and how you wanted to
chemistry to be there once you did come
together I mean for series she is you
know she's driven to find Geralt because
she's lost all her family
within one night she's lost everybody
and so she wants to find that family
again and so it's very very important
for her because she's feeling lonely and
she's feeling lost and and you know she
she she needs Darrell and she needs
answers and so that's what drives her to
find garel I'm just wondering since so
much of this season is about the
bringing together the characters how you
how you wanted your your chemistry to be
once once the core characters are
finally together she's really important
I meet Darrell in this Caesar series and
that was you know it's a very intense
relationship they have and you know I
was able to have a lot of conversations
with Henry and with the director and
Lauren about what that relate well aware
that kawaii that's so complicated I know
that the fans absolutely love it and
then I don't meet Cirie in this season
but I'm very excited to some point her
mind again this is this is going to
specific so I won't i won't i won't i
won't real question what i do want to
talk specifically about a seen the
transformation scene which is a very
intense gnarly scene to film i'm
wondering what that the preparation was
for that both physically and mentally
and what that was like
on the day sort of staying in that
headspace when you're filming it over
and over i think i have a tendency to
overthink a lot of things so it was
really important that i you know with
that I just trusted my instincts I
didn't plan anything really I've been
playing Jennifer for a while up until
that moment and I knew I always knew
where I had been where I was going and
that's all I really needed to know
everything else was kind of done for me
in those set and a costume and blood and
sweat and you know and the fire and
yeah and I all I needed to do was
express that pain really I mean that was
hot it's not all I needs to do it was it
was yeah I had I could have come out
that day feeling very depressed but I
was working with Julie writer who was an
absolute dream to work with and the
funniest man one of the funniest men
I've ever met so he kept the mood light
and one of the things I learned from him
is to you know he takes her work very
seriously but actually it's really
important to not take yourself too
seriously especially when you're doing
scenes like that and a lot of Jennifers
journey was very intense and emotionally
challenging this is one of those rare
shows that has a season two before
season 1 premieres I'm wondering if
there's anything you learned from living
in these characters for a season that
that has changed your preparation
heading into a zoo the zoo or now in
your preparation just the way you
approach the headspace of these two
characters yeah I've just learnt a lot
there are certain things that I wouldn't
you know when I wouldn't approach
certain scenes in the way I did certain
things I would have loved to have
changed but that's not helpful I can
take what I learned from that and move
on to season 2 there's a lot that you
know I grew with yennefer in that in
that season I learned a lot that was all
new
now I've heard we've had eight months
with the with with these characters and
so we can we've really owned them and
you know trust in that and hopefully the
response that we get will only support
us in that yeah I think almost the
growth and how much we've learned
ourselves will kind of almost transfer
into the into the characters we'll
definitely for serene first well when
when we do season two